una imagen insólita después de 40 horas
en autobús decenas de venezolanos
desembarcan sorprendidos frente a la
residencia de la vicepresidenta de
Estados Unidos cámara Harris imágenes
que simbolizan la más reciente disputada
bipartidista
este autobús como otros que han llegado
a Washington y Nueva York y dos aviones
que aterrizaron en el Balneario
exclusivo de martas vineiart son parte
de una campaña de gobernadores
republicanos como los de Texas y Florida
que buscan Mostrar el presunto fracaso
de las políticas migratorias de los
demócratas enviando a los migrantes a
circunscripciones donde Estos son
mayoritarias las comunidades y las ong
se solidarizan con los migrantes quienes
a menudo se sorprenden de a donde los
han enviado los estamos trasladando
ahora mismo a un lugar seguro donde
podamos darles comida un espacio para
descansar y una muda de ropa limpia los
demócratas señalan a los republicanos
tras esta decisión show Drake gobernador
de Texas y ron de santis de Florida de
hacer una jugada política previa a las
elecciones de medio término de noviembre
algunos residentes en el balneario
veraniego de martas vine y Art se
solidarizan con esta idea es realmente
molesto estas pobres personas han sido
utilizadas y realmente lo siento por
ellos los migrantes asentados en la isla
fueron trasladados a una base militar
cercana en keikot Nueva York recibió
tres buses con migrantes provenientes de
Texas este sábado muchos de ellos
venezolanos que expresan alivio de estar
por fin en territorio estadounidense Por
fin lo logramos después de pasar tanto
tiempo México Ya un mes pasando México
Por fin lo logramos según la
organización internacional de las
migraciones en lo ocurrido de 2022 han
sido interceptados más de un millón de
migrantes